this is the dream of the web is this the
thing that everyone always wanted I mean
I started working on the web many many
years ago and back then they were
actually selling software that
specifically said what you see is what
you get
we had fireworks we had Dreamweaver we
had flash we had front-page the idea was
you would open an editor and then he
would place content in some sort of view
and then that content would appear in
the same place in the exact same way in
the web browser it was a fantastic idea
of course it didn't actually work at all
but you know that's how I used to be the
reason why it was like that is because
everyone wants that to happen everyone
once it to be that way that we can just
place content somewhere and then
everyone else will see the content in
the same place today we have things like
wicks and Squarespace which sell
themself the exact same way they say
without actually using the words what
you see is what you get we also have
these new weird things happening like
this this is the grid it's an
application where you just dump content
in and some AI figures out how to
display things in the right way
we have medium and its ilk which are
actually what you see is what you get
except they're just publishing
straight-up content and then we have
WordPress and we're persistent oddball
because in WordPress we actually say we
have what you see is what you get but
the person who comes to WordPress for
the first time and goes to the backend
and starts writing content this is what
they see and this is what they get which
you know is
what you see is what you get if the what
you see is the content and nothing else
and then not the header or the footer or
the sidebar or any of the other content
provided the theme author and plug-in
developers also added in editor styles
so it's awesome now the reason why I
talk about this is because when
WordPress was first developed and pretty
much everything we know about web design
was happening everyone was working on
these things remember those things it
was like you had a TV they sat on top of
a big box then held typewriter next to
it and then you have this big blocky
thing and you can move around some
people put it on the floor and thought
it was a foot pedal that is when the web
was created and that is actually how we
still think about the web as this thing
that everyone sees in a small little
screen that's fixed so we know what that
screen is like the problem is today the
landscape is totally different everyone
walks around with one of those glass
bars in their pocket and all those glass
bars have different sizes people have
laptops or tablets or tablets that turn
into laptops or laptops you can split
apart and fold soon they will actually
have phones they can fold and then in
addition there are these new things
happening or they're shipping these
bizarre looking glasses that people put
on their faces and then they see
something new and this is highly
relevant to us because that's where
things are going so today I want you to
do a thought experiment with me I want
you to take your imaginary VR goggles
and put them on forget everything you
know about WordPress forget everything
you know about Gutenberg now let's look
at Gutenberg and the word press of
tomorrow if you have any complaints
about this talk please tweet me at
Morton that's my name so I need to take
you back to San Francisco 2013 that was
the I believe the
last time we had WordCamp san francisco
the year after it became WordCamp us and
at every word camp San Francisco now us
Matt Mullenweg there's a talk called the
state of the word where he talks about
what has happened in WordPress and what
will happen at this particular event
that's a very end of the talk he brought
up some really interesting slides and he
said we're thinking about doing new
things in WordPress and one of the
things that's come up is this idea of
inline contextual editing of content and
another thing that we've been thinking
about is providing types of content
within the post so rather than just
writing paragraphs and headings and
other stuff you actually mark off what
those things are and then he showed this
slide this is courtesy of Joe and
Asmussen and Mel choice I believe melt
is in this building I don't know if
she's here I can't see anyway so hiding
somewhere 2013 all right now the concept
has since become something people are
used to on the web if you go to medium
and you type out content you have this
little plus sign and you click on the
plus sign and you get contextual
features if you go to LinkedIn polls you
have the same thing you type in some
content you click this little icon and
you get contextual features and if you
go to WordPress with Guttenberg we now
have the same thing except in WordPress
it's not just small contextual little
features it is a whole ton of new
features they're all packaged into this
entirely new way of editing everything
that's going on inside the content
editor I'm going to give you a short
live demo because I've lost my mind
this is just a stock install of
WordPress with running the current
version I hope and this is with
Gutenberg running so I've written a
small little post for you it's just
called
what is coudn't burg anyway and this is
what good bird looks like so it is the
content editor but the content editor
has a bunch of new features in it for
example as you can see this post has
some subheadings and some other stuff
going on and there's a little info icon
up here you can open it and tells me the
word count tells me how many paragraphs
they have it even gives me a table of
contents so I can see the structure of
my document so there's some new stuff
going on here but what's really
important is what's happening inside the
editor itself because each of these
things that you see here are now
considered blocks so when I select the
block
I see contextual information about that
item so here you can see this is
currently just a paragraph I can now
change this to anything else so I can
change it to a quote if I don't like the
look of it I can change it to a
different kind of quote if I don't like
that I can just go back and change it to
your paragraph again I can also change
into a heading and your whole bunch of
other stuff but that's you know a block
oh yeah nothing new here so what if I
want to add something else let's say I
want to create a layout where I have two
things next to one another I used to be
a something you needed a plug-in for but
if I go to blocks now I can text columns
so I can set up a column here and
another column over here and then I
realize you know what I actually need
more columns than two
so in this you're seeing something
really new and unique in WordPress that
wasn't there before and that is you can
go into individual elements and start
working on those elements as individual
pieces and those individual pieces have
properties to them and those properties
can be controlled and the properties
change depending on what kind of content
to this so this is a three column to a
block now if I go up to one of my
paragraphs here see I'll go to this one
you'll see the block context over here
on the right-hand side changes and now I
get things like text size so I can
change the text size of just that block
I get a background color option I get a
text color option and even if I pick a
really poorly choice in color air you'll
see it even tells me that that's not the
best option and if I then add in
something new let's say I want to add an
image I can also do that right here I
just say I want a new block I want to
block to be an image then I can upload
or insert a media gallery here's an
image of some old man the context now
tells me this is a image I should
probably have an alternative text on it
I can write a caption for it and if I
want to change it I can change the size
of it and then change its positioning
until I get what I want then I click
update and go to the front end here we
have the post with my image my three
columns my rear'd blue box and this
shows you editing and WordPress changes
in a fundamental way because you now
have individualized control of all the
little pieces this is important because
the main challenge of WYSIWYG
or what you see is what you get was
always that is very hard to identify
what the little things are inside any
type of content
so what Gutenberg tries to do is
identify all the pieces of content you
put in to a post or eventually
everything else in WordPress and then
give that item properties so we can
control it this is totally new and
totally different from how WordPress s
worked in before and it all works based
on blocks and block contexts so I showed
you a bunch of them here we have a
paragraph block which has a bunch of
color options and other things you have
an image block that gives you the
ability to add contextual information
about the image you have column blocks
where you can choose how many columns
you want and how they're laid out we
have heading blocks that give us heading
control we have block quote blocks to
give us block code control we have image
blocks and cover image blocks where you
can support a super impulse text on top
of images and even provide a background
color on top of the image before the
text we have the read more block which
used to just be a line that's let's read
more where you can now say read more and
then you can choose whether or not the
visitor actually sees the text before or
not when they go to the single post
we have pullquote block which just
they've used to be there
there's even new things like widgets
that exists inside blocks you can add
them to posts and pages and all this
happens
in a rather interesting way so behind
the curtain this is what it looks like
might be a little hard to see what's
happening right now is when you create a
block you're actually putting little
HTML comments inside the content that
identify each of the blocks and then
these little HTML comments will have
properties assigned to them so you can
go in and look at the HTML comments now
that's not to say you have to learn the
language of this in fact if you go to an
individual block inside the editor you
can click the little Donaire menu on the
side and go on edit the output HTML that
comes from it right inside your editor
so you can open just a block just a tad
add HTML and then edit the rest of the
content as if it was regular content
sorry uncle Ernie we'll leave it alone
in theory now this of course brings up
an obvious question the it brings up an
obvious question which is all this stuff
lives inside the content blob now the
answer is yes it does and we're just
gonna ignore that the more important
thing is this opens up all these new
opportunities for us because if we have
the ability to set up blocks and set
properties onto those blocks we can
start doing all sorts of crazy things
that we could not do before and some
companies are starting to explore this
and figure out what they can do so
Yoast is looking at the possibility of
adding contextual information to
individual and blocks and tell you
whether or not they're good for SEO that
includes things like if you add an image
you'll see SEO plugin can tell you hey
you need to add an alternate text to
this image otherwise it doesn't work
properly it means you can go in and tell
you the readability of individual blocks
because you have contextual control and
they're looking at adding our SEO and
readability feedback as comments inside
text basically someone can look at it
and add additional information and all
this is made possible because we are now
working on individual block elements
mattias is one of the people who are
working on this project wrote a post
called Gutenberg and the ship of theseus
where he said imagine defining a whole
page template as a set of default blocks
ready to be filled once the user creates
a page this is also important because I
think anyone who's built a site knows
that you build a side you go this is the
type of content needs to go on the side
for it to look good and we hand it over
to client and then they do something
totally different and then they call you
and they go it looks like crap you're
like yeah well you didn't do anything I
told you so it looks like crap right but
if you can provide them with an actual
Ridgid template and say no you fill in
this template and then they look exactly
the way we wanted to well you can
because you can feed in a template of
blocks to your WordPress and say here is
the template you just fill in the blocks
as I've set them up and then everything
will look okay you also say Gutenberg
aims to give developers a way to define
and protect structural markup and their
design while giving users the ability to
directly edit the information intuitive
so in English terms it means you as a
developer or designer should be able to
figure out how things should be laid out
and then still give the end user control
over the individual content that goes
inside there so for example if you
wanted to have a layout or you have
these three buckets where each of them
has an image and then some text
underneath you can provide that as
templates that people can add the three
bucket blog blog block and then they can
just fill in the content automatically
and you can even make it so that they
can't save unless they've done it
properly because you can add contextual
information and you can style individual
blocks both ones that ship and the ones
that can come in you can be sorry
Gutenberg grants block control to
developers so developer can say I know
how paragraph blocks are styled from
WordPress I don't like that so I'm gonna
change it to something else that's
something you can now do as a theme
developer and it will follow with the
theme or the plug-in you're using but
the really cool thing is themes and
plugins can introduce new blocks
so one of the examples is WooCommerce
they were experimented with what they I
forget what they call it is something
we're like ooh blocks something like
that where products and product displace
are blocks that you can place anywhere I
have a random idea I know a comic book
artist really likes to publish comments
and she's always complaining about how
it's hard to layout comments so you can
make a comic book block where you can
create different types of block layouts
that they get loaded in they just select
the layout I'm gonna apply the images
they want inside that layout laid out
exactly you want this okay
it just CSS grid it'll take like five
lines of code I don't know about that I
don't know about the actual JavaScript
but the CSS part of it is super easy you
can create a layout selector so when a
user goes in to create a new post they
can pick which layout they're going to
work on and then supply that layout this
is something that other companies are
doing already human made made this
really complex layout selector for a
newspaper they were working on this is
not possible inside they're also working
on this concept of repeatable blocks
where you add a piece of content in one
post or one page and you go actually I
need to use that somewhere else so if
you write an article about Kafka and
there's metamorphosis and you go I might
mention Kafka bio some other place you
can make it a repeatable block and then
say oh here's a another page I'm just
gonna add it there as well and also on
this other page and if you edit any one
of them
it'll edits and all the other places too
so if you were selling a book you just
make the one repeatable block in one
place place it wherever you want
anywhere else on the site now this begs
an obvious question if Gutenberg is an
editor replacement this makes no sense
why would you have repeatable blocks
inside editor well the reality is
Gutenberg was never an editor
replacement I'll repeat that Gutenberg
was never an editor replacement
Gutenberg is more like WordPress trying
to become actual with a wig so right now
this is what you see this is what
Gutenberg looks like an actual editor
replacement and that's because the way
that we've been designing websites is
something like this you have a header
you have some sort of nav thing you have
a big content blob you have a sidebar
you have a footer or some sort of layout
like that and right now Gutenberg sits
in the content block but that's just
because we're used to doing things that
way and the reason why the Gutenberg
team is working only inside the content
editor simply because that's the logical
place to start that is not where it ends
this way of doing things is soon going
to go away what we'll end up with is
something altogether different see good
Burgas greedy he wants to take over the
whole view not just not just the content
but everything so what we have right now
is this concept of blocks that you place
inside the content editor you can
combine them in any way you want but the
next step is for both blocks to go
beyond just the editor to everywhere I
think the next step in the process is
there customizer and logically in the
customizer you would think there you can
customize a lot of things like all the
widget diced areas and the header and
the footer and all these other things
but the thing is remember how I said the
world is changing and people for glasses
on this concept of a viewport is going
away and these blocks should be able to
live anywhere now if everything is a
block a lot of things change so if you
look at the list of things that they're
currently working on you'll see there's
a lot of things that are becoming blocks
this is the current potential blocks
list so caveat maybe none of this
happens but we have recent Commons
tagcloud search author bio slideshow
logo social legs cover video Appa
growling latest polls custom menu all
these things can be blocks and in
addition you'll have all the plug-in
things and all the
things that people will introduce so
imagine you're writing a pulse then you
go hey I actually need to provide a link
to the recent pulse Teresa comment so
you can just dump that in this block or
you're working on an entire view and you
said it would be relevant here to
provide a link to the most recent
comments I'm just gonna dump that into
the sidebar or you say well in this
particular view I want a nice looking
list of the pulse at the top or in the
middle or on the bottom or you say I
really need a chat somewhere so I'm
gonna put a chat in the footer or a
slideshow that needs to go in the header
for some reason you can place these
blocks anywhere you want but you have to
start thinking beyond just this little
viewport you see the web up until this
point has been confined to some sort of
rectangular screen but that is not how
it's going to be and Gutenberg has the
potential of moving us into the next
time when we go beyond that because
we're in this weird situation now where
we're designing everything based on the
very old methodology and within this old
methodology Gutenberg fits well inside
the content editor the next step is to
move we work inside the whole view and
then to like Gutenberg take over
everything and I know what look people
like the gerber teams like so caveat
we're not doing any VR stuff right now
there's zero VR plans yes oh there are
there are pull requests on VR that's
awesome but pull requests welcome yes go
write them afterwards and this is
actually what what you see is what you
get is all about is this idea of
creating a block and placing it wherever
you want it to appear and then have
other people experience that where they
wanted to appear now you have to think
about what you see is what you get a
little bit different from how we're done
it so far just in our heads what you see
is what you get is this thing that
happens where I look at a screen and
then I make something and then I expose
that to someone else in the future what
you see is what you get is something
that the user will say
so they will go in and say I want all
the logos for all the sites I go to to
be up here in this space and I want all
the menus to be up over here so I know
where they are in my vr space or
something like that and Gutenberg allows
us to do that which brings us back to
this what-you-see-is-what-you-get thing
and what I want you to do right now so
what you see is what you get only works
if we all start contributing it's not
what you see is what you get is what you
test is what you get it's not what you
see is what you get is what you
contribute is what you get it's not what
you see is what you get it's what you
build it's what you get and every single
person in this room has the knowledge
and the ability to test contribute and
build even if you've never touched
WordPress before and you just happen to
go toward camp us as your first ever
WordPress experience in which case I
welcome you you are the most impersonal
important person in this room you can
contribute either today now probably now
today tomorrow or on Sunday you can go
test Gutenberg with one of the Gutenberg
team and provide feedback or you can
download gutenberg install it as a
plugin start testing it and then file
tickets on the github repo and provide
your feedback to the team that includes
your vr ticket so test gutenberg today
contribute your ideas and build the
future you want with Gutenberg and of
course make an accessible
thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]